someone has never seen anything you've
directed before what is the first thing
you'd like them watching and why I think
maybe to watch um that's a good question
um I was G look the I think the movies
that are really most representative of
or people that are you know The
Illusionist and Limitless so you know
maybe the maybe limit it depends on who
they are you know there's certain
there's like Limitless lovers and
there's Illusionist lovers and then you
know I also was going to say you know
you start at the beginning if you look
at my first film which is called
interview with the Assassin I don't know
if you've ever seen it but it's um it's
I I really like that movie and it's a
really evocative of of or representative
of how who I am as a filmmaker the way
it's done and the risks that we take and
the way we choose to we chose to tell
that tell that story so so I haven't
answered your question at all except um
um yeah maybe maybe Limitless which of
your films changed the most in the
editing room in ways you didn't expect
there isn't really they were they were
pretty much as they were conceived um I
would say voyagers just to be completely
honest with you was the one that I had
sort of the most difficulty with
with you know producers and things like
that so um and so I suppose that might
be the one that that that changed the
most so I'm still proud of the film and
I'm proud of that cast and things like
that but that got moved around that that
is the one that changed the most
actually come now all coming to the
thing yeah uh not to not to devote too
much time to it but was that because
people wanted you to focus on other
things or were you trying to hit a
rating or you know partly we were trying
to hit a rating suddenly we were like
why are we getting an our rating for
this and they wanted it to because there
were so many young people in it they
wanted it to appeal to young people so
we changed some things and partly
because the concept of that of that
Voyage is a a concept of exploration at
least as it was in in the written script
and nobody could sort of deal with that
they wanted it to be like well the
planet is dying and so we have to flee
the planet and so which was like why we
know that story already why do we why do
we care just this is what's happening
why can't we just be in space this maybe
that's why or maybe it's because it's
and and it it became like imperative for
some reason to sort of create this whole
I don't know to explain too much and um
uh and I didn't do as uh as much as was
wanted but I think any of it is was was
too much yeah um I also think that uh
it's it's interesting because I also
think that um sometimes explaining less
is better because the people's imag
ination is always going to be more
powerful right right you take your movie
to preview screening and people are like
I don't understand why they were they
never told us why they were leaving it
was like does that matter that we never
told you that and so but then people are
like well we should tell them why
because they said which I don't actually
think that that just because they have
the question doesn't mean that sometimes
okay to have a question you know yeah
there's the difference between I don't
want to say there's a difference between
producers and artists but you know
anyway there's also a difference between
like um
confusion and ambiguity and you know and
holes and app PL you know there's
different things where sometimes they
get all lumped together it's like it's
okay that it's like left unsaid or it's
withheld or something like that I
completely agree so jumping into why I
get to talk to you what was it about
this story that said I have to make this
well I actually had been looking to make
a movie that was said in nature where
the Wilderness and where the natural
world world was a like a almost a
character in it and so this was
definitely that and then I also like
this story of of this woman who
had kind of where the past comes back to
haunt the present um where it's like
what if the person that she loved the
most turns out to be a monster what do
you do with that where do you and in her
case you know she put it in a box and
she buried it and she never dealt with
it again and you you know does that work
maybe that works um and for her it
almost does work and then then it all
comes you know crashing down and falling
apart so I was interested in that story
of you know can this woman and can
anybody change the way they were shaped
as a child can they free themselves in
her case can she can she free herself
from the trauma of her past or can any
of us change who we are in a substantial
way and become the person that we want
to be when you are making a movie based
on a popular book do you sort of accept
that there's just going to be people
that don't like what you're doing
because you're deviating somehow from
the book or do you sort of like do you
know what I mean because I do yeah like
so I'm just curious what's your mindset
when you're making something like this
do you sort of just have to accept that
there's going to be certain people that
don't come along for the ride you we you
know I don't think I ever accept that
but I do know that that's the risk that
there are that there are people that
are you know they have look the
readership any the whole readership like
from the get-go they have their own
images of what the actors look like how
the scene unfolds whatever it is and so
in a way I want to understand that and I
have my own images as well which is sort
of where what I'm building off of and I
hope that that that
somehow like with an honest kind of
um uh sort of exploration of those
characters that it may not be exactly
what you were thinking of but it's
expressive in a similar way to the to
the original and and look ultimately a
movie is a different it's a different
art form it's a different Beast it has
different needs it has different uh uh
you know sort of narrative uh you know
issues and um
uh
so you it's going to be different and
you're yes there's always people that
are going to be unhappy but hopefully
very few and hopefully you make
something that's as sort of as
expressive as possible and kind of as I
don't know as juicy and as meaty as the
original or more so that then they can
kind of you know just invest into what
what's put right in front of them so you
made this movie in 37 days which is a
very tight schedule to begin with but
then you decided to film in very remote
places that were so off the beaten path
at what point of the shoot were you like
what the f was I thinking well I mean
I'm like experienced enough and old
enough that I knew what I was getting
into you know they really you know when
you shoot in um when you shoot in like
the woods you know where they want you
to shoot they want you to shoot like at
a ski resort where you can just where
there's a parking lot right next to you
know some woods and but I was looking
for forests and Wilderness that felt
like or even Primal that had kind
of like that mysterious quality to them
that they like they'd never been logged
before that they were untouched um uh
because I thought just thematically
thematically that was important and
somehow visually that we needed to have
that the proper representation for that
and so so we found it and they and they
were remote as you said and I always
think that it was worth it it was brutal
it was really hard and we did crazy
things you know we had to have like our
equipment helicoptered in um to certain
remote locations the helicopters
couldn't even land they had to like
lower it like on a cable you know with a
with a cargo net with the equipment
inside like on the edge of a on the like
just on the edge of a of a riverbank and
um like there was only you know whatever
15 feet of like a Rocky River Bank for
them to land their stuff on it was tough
and the crew worked really hard and I'm
like you know indebted to the crew for
their hard work but they pulled together
and they they did it and the the cast
also um hiked into places and no no
amenities no like no dressing rooms no
toilets even in certain cases or no and
um you know and it was rough and we had
to adapt to that and they we
unfortunately we had the schedule was
longer and then for whatever reasons
because of coid and things like that
which is going on as well you know they
started like just running out of money
and we had cut days and so you know as a
filmmaker it makes you very Nimble you
know you have to adapt and you're like
okay we thought we were going to shoot
it like this but we're going to actually
find a more interesting simpler way to
do it um that often is more interesting
so yeah I think uh every filmaker I've
spoken to said that the um overcoming
the adversity of making a movie can
sometimes make your film better because
you're forced to creatively find you
know ways to solve your problems yes if
it doesn't destroy it hopefully it makes
it better exactly either either option
is is on the table so uh so you get in
the editing room you have a cut you're
showing it to friends and family uh what
are you learning from those early
screenings that impacted the finished
film that's a good question I think
we're learning things about the suspense
and about the Thriller quality of it
when people are engaged when they're not
how you know what's interesting about
the movie is that it's it is a thriller
and wants to be a thriller and uh but
it's also has a very alongside it is a
very you know deep exploration of a
certain character you know and and we're
very much her emotional Journey um and
her life and her you know the way she is
and the way she interacts with other
people is important to look I always say
that like the best thrillers are the
ones where you are as connected as
possible to the character so the more
you know the character the more you're
invested in the character The More The
Thrill Ride is going to be that much you
know suspenseful or tense or scary or
whatever and so so I think what so
there's a lot this is Char so it was
learning that balance of how much
character how much uh you know how much
how much character could we get away
with or how much how much could we take
out and still get what we wanted how
much did we have to have in how much was
too much that sort of thing did you end
up with a lot of deleted scenes we did
actually we did yeah is it like 10
minutes or like more like 25 no it's
like maybe like 10 minutes of scenes and
it's often because we had a lot I think
a lot of it was in the beginning um in
um with the the childhood things the
childhood stuff was so rich to me you
know that their interaction and what
went on and there was a lot of a lot of
things that were that we cut out
actually just to get into the story a
bit quicker you know to get to Daisy's
character a little bit sooner yeah no I
I understand also like you know the
stuff with Brooklyn and Ben was so good
that you almost want to spend more time
there I know you do but but then there's
a whole other story to tell so no 100%
so I have to ask you because I'm running
out of time uh what are you thinking
about doing next do you know what you're
doing I've already shot another movie um
and it's um it's called inheritance
actually and it's um it's with Phoebe
Davore do you know Phoebe Phoebe was in
Bridgton and um and she's great and it's
a movie that goes around the world
actually it goes from from um it goes
from New York to Cairo to Delhi to seou
and back to New York and we took the
trip and it was an amazing adventure
it's so funny because I stalked your
Instagram last night and I saw these
pictures from uh uh where you were and I
was like what was he doing in all these
places I know we were keeping it as
secret we're just in the middle we're
we're we're selling the movie right now
and um the movie's done but um and so we
were keeping it a we we we the whole we
had this idea that we're going to keep
the movie a secret while we were making
it which we did um you're one of the
first people I've said anything in
public to besides to friends I'm not
sure why I did but I did so um by the
way I I app well it's because I'm a fan
and you know it um so C can I ask you
because I don't want to get you in
trouble but do you can you tell people
what it's about or are you keeping that
a mystery it's an international Thriller
that's what I'm I'll say got it are you
selling it at AFM no it's already in
it's already in its we were we we were
at Toronto and we were we were uh kind
of just in the in the mark in the market
side of Toronto I I totally get what
you're saying I know other people that
were selling films at the at Toronto
without advertising they were there
that's right and so we're just in the
the deal making is like taking forever
but it seems to be you know it's moving
so so basically I get to see it next
year that's correct yes I look forward
to seeing it and talking to you again
for it and um I'm out of time I'm just
going to say you know wish you nothing
but the best and let me know I can help
you on collider excellent appreciate it
all right Steve thanks so much good talk
have a great day thank
you